[Musique]
prenez votre voiture tous les matins
pour aller travailler
et pourquoi avoir ce qui n'a pas de
transports en commun ce n'est pas qu'il
ya des 33 transport comme un mythe chez
moi ce n'est pas pratique pour et je
compte sur paris vous travaillez ou il
vous habitez ou gmail arrivé j'ai
travaillé ici et pour vous passiez par
paris pour parler qu'on peut encore en
commun et ça vous fait combien de trajet
je prenais transports en commun en
faudrait bien compter 1h30 et vous
mettez combien de temps voiture en
voiture je me mets à peu près 35 minutes
comme ça roule bien
[Musique]
savoir si vous prenez votre voiture tous
les matins pour aller travailler tous
les matins
pourquoi vous n'avez pas de transports
en commun les années douces mais je
parle de de châtillon sous bagneux
continue et s'il y avait des transports
en commun voulait prendriez il ya des
transports en commun mais c'est trop
difficile pour moi de les utiliser je
voyage un petit peu trop dans paris et
vous avez vous avez les tous les jours
travailler avec votre voiture vous
prenez votre voiture tous les matins
pour aller travailler
vous n'avez pas transports en commun le
chercher
à la porte documents mais
chassés si vous aviez des transports
vous le prendriez
à bail en banlieue et j'habite en
banlieue jeu
relativement peu de transports en commun
ce qui me concerne nous habite et oui
vous travail où j'habite châtillon sous
bagneux je travaille à clamart et ça
serait facile pour vous de voyager en
transport en commun
vous prenez votre voiture tous les
matins pour aller travailler
vous n'avez pas de transports en commun
et ça ne vous fait rien dépenser de
l'argent pour les sens on va quand même
pas tellement plaisant satisfaisant ici
dans la région
oui passerait bien
ap les jours j'en ai fait remarquer que
le travail voyez j'accompagne afin de
coller
et vous prenez votre voiture pourquoi
aller à l'école je suis un séducteur et
vous n'avez pas de transport en commun
n'est pas de transport vous prenez votre
voiture pour aller travailler
pourquoi vous n'avez pas de transports
en commun
et s'il y en avait voulait prendriez si
nous aussi si vous voulez prendre
actuellement par où vous devez passer à
paris je suis actuellement à rueil
malmaison mais je veux me rendre à
epinay sur seine
deux solutions s'offrent à moi ou bien
je prends le rer qui sont derrière moi
je vais jusqu'à paris
là je prends le métro je ré jusqu'à la
gare du nord et je prends le train pour
me rendre à l'épinette deuxième solution
je prends les transports transversaux et
je vais commencer par prendre le rer et
voilà ce que ça donne
[Musique]
[Rires]
à
beaucoup
[Musique]
11h20 les à argenteuil c'est à dire
qu'il m'a fallu prendre si moyen de
transport cinq changements des escaliers
à descendre des escaliers à monter au
fait je suis pas encore à epinay il faut
encore que je prenne un autocar qui va
m'emmener à la cité d'epinay un autocar
qui mettra environ 10 minutes pour aller
là bas c'est à dire que dorval maison à
epinay j'aurais mis près d'une heure et
demie pour faire une vingtaine de
kilomètres l'augmentation du nombre des
déplacements entre les banlieues
représente 70 % de l'augmentation
annuelle totale des déplacements dans la
région parisienne
deux raisons à cela le développement des
villes nouvelles à la périphérie de la
capitale
cergy pontoise saint quentin en yvelines
evry traitait d'autre part le
desserrement des emplois de paris vers
la banlieue quinze mille par an on
assiste aussi à une sorte de décalage
entre l'est et l'ouest de paris
les bureaux se concentre surtout à
l'ouest avec notamment
toute la zone de la défense
les constructions de logements elle se
développe plus tôt dans le reste de
l'agglomération parisienne où les prix
des terrains sont moins chers bien qu'en
nette amélioration la coordination entre
la construction des bureaux et celle des
logements n'est donc pas encore tout à
fait satisfaisant
la sncf fait des efforts importants pour
améliorer son réseau de banlieue sont
hors amm en 1974 s'élève à 340 millions
de francs
à cela s'ajoute une tranche spéciale de
253 millions financé avec l'aide de
l'état et du district de la région
parisienne
mais tous ces travaux d'équipement
concerne essentiellement les lignes qui
permettent les déplacements entre la
banlieue et paris
dans toutes ces améliorations aucune
intéresse le banlieusard qui travaille
dans une autre banlieue que celle où il
habite
ce dont il a besoin lui ce sont des
rocades
c'est à dire des lignes qui tourne
autour de paris or ces requins existent
elles ont pour nom petit et grande
ceinture réserve au transport de
marchandises
il suffirait de les rouvrir au trafic
voyageur cela nécessiterait bien sûr
quelques travaux de rénovation et la
construction de gares je pense que la
sncf doit regarder comment on peut
desservir de banlieue à banlieue car on
a toujours des services de paris à
banlieue et non pas de banlieue à
banlieue
je pense aussi qu'on peut relancer les
taxis collectifs c'est qu'il ya des
taxis collectifs mais très peu qui
existe aux portes de paris est en fait
pour desservir les lignes où il n'y a
pas de transports en commun
il est possible de relancer les taxis
collectifs et puis ya enfin la
bicyclette je crois beaucoup que la
bicyclette doit être relancée mais à
partir du moment où il y aura des pistes
cyclables et sur ce plan là il y a un
immense effort à faire il faut que le
gouvernement a des cheveux longs des
directions de l'équipement regarde le
problème est qu'on dépense beaucoup plus
que ce qui est prévu pour les pistes
cyclables puisque dans le budget 74 ya
50 millions d'anciens francs seul
[Musique]
problèmes de la banlieue à banlieue doit
être revue parce que vous avez en région
parisienne 40% des gens qui font trois
kilomètres seulement pour leurs
déplacements
donc on doit pouvoir y arriver en
bicyclette taxis collectifs voiture
collective aussi faut que les gens qui
habitent dans un même endroit et qui
travaille à peu près dans une même ville
puisse organiser à monter cap dans une
voiture au lieu de une seule personne et
de partager les frais d'essence ce qui
fait que c'est moins cher souvent que le
transport collectif
je crois qu'il faut que les gens se
connaissent qui cèdent les uns les
autres et qui se retrouvent
[Musique]